françois bayrou est l'invité de preuves
par 3 merci d'être avec nous monsieur
bayrou et bienvenue sur ce plateau dont
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité évidemment c'est ce qu'on attend
de vous puisque c'est votre credo de la
vérité en politique
chez plon vous avez décidé de poursuivre
le dialogue direct avec les français
mais tant que vous n'avez plus de mandat
national et dans ce dialogue avec les
français
vous fustigez les mauvaises pratiques
politiques qui empêchent selon vous le
redressement de la france dans un
instant pierre guy czerny de l' agence
france-presse et puis perrine tarneaud
de public sénat
nous rejoindrons dailymotion est
également comme chaque semaine le
partenaire de cette émission
cela permet au téléspectateur
d'intervenir directement de vous
interpeller le pic du chômage de 1997
heureusement n'a pas été battu avec les
derniers chiffres du mois de février
néanmoins évidemment il ya une
aggravation de la situation avec 3
millions 187 milles plus 26500
demandeurs d'emploi en france il ya le
feu ça veut dire que 260 familles par
département moyens sont atteintes à leur
tour par le chômage qui est donc
évidemment c c'est une vague c'est un
c'est un tsunami qui détruit sur son
passage
le
la confiance des des gens le l'unité des
familles
l'idée que les gens se font de même
c'est doux c'est humainement extrêmement
dure et ce qui est le plus dur
j'allais dire civiquement c'est qu'on
voit pas le chemin pour en sortir ou on
voit pas la fin
il ya des mesures qui sont mises en
avant encore par le premier ministre
appelle à la mobilisation générale
mais ce quand on vous parle de mesure ça
veut dire que le plan d'ensemble est
insuffisant les mesures c'est
parcellaire c'est un kaléidoscope
mais ça n'est rien qui fasse la force
d'une action politique
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait vous réclamez
mois après mois d'ailleurs après chaque
publication des chiffres du chômage des
mesures radicales vtr une je réclame une
politique d'urgence pour que ceux qui
sont en première ligne et je vais donner
leur définition et ceux qui signent les
contrats de travail
ceux qui ont du travail ce qui crée du
travail pour les autres pour que cela
soit soutenue au lieu d'être freinée
alors surtout pas une mesure parmi
d'autres
oh il y en a plein on pourrait imaginer
une mesure sur les seuils savez c'est
celle qui font de 10 à 20 de 50 et au
delà
on pourrait imaginer une mesure qui
touche au seuil élèves les seuils
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres des
russes seulement c'est sûr général en
quelque sorte dont je suis ça pas sûr
que ce soit des réglementations je parle
de choses qui empêche les entreprises
d'embaucher le nombre de ceux qui se
développerait le carcan le droit du
travail un nra le barreau dit j'ai une g
dans une émission récente montré le code
du travail suisse et le code du travail
français l'un pèse 190 grammes et
l'autre pèse 2 kg
est ce que les salariés sont mieux
protégés dans un cas que dans l'autre en
tout cas c'est intéressant parce que la
suisse un pays qui a pas de matière
première qui a des salaires plus élevés
que les nôtres et même dans un certain
nombre de cas beaucoup plus élevés que
les nôtres et qui exportent qui produit
qui créent de l'emploi puisqu'il ya
trois cent mille français qui traverse à
la frontière tous les jours alors c'est
pas fascination pour le modèle
helvétique ne peux pas mais comparer les
deux économies non plus
mais pourquoi abbas quelles questions là
et on se compare généralement plus à la
une par exemple oui mais c'est pour
éviter c'est pour éviter de 2,2 toujours
resté dans la alors la comparaison avec
l'allemagne comme julie politique
d'urgence soutient des créateurs
d'emplois et de ressources pour le pays
comment un en supprimant tout ce qui les
bloquent en mettant les forces du pays
notamment de meta pour les aider et pas
pour les freiner alors ça veut dire une
politique fiscale différentes y compris
qui leur permettent quand ils créent de
l'emploi et des ressources devaient
envoyer de l'argent s'enrichir sais pas
si c'est le mot est de gagner de
l'argent
une politique dans lequel les pme et les
petites entreprises et les artisans se
sentiraient en confiance et pas
constamment traquer avec des règles qui
soient des règles simples et de long
terme au lieu d'avoir des règles attrait
qui change tous les jours et qui les
menacent vous voyez bien que ça c'est
une politique complètement différent que
ce que nous avons fait depuis 20 ans et
réclamé la vérité quand le chef de
l'état dit qu'il parie toujours sur une
inversion de la courbe du chômage à la
fin d'année il ment non il
c'est une profession d'optimisme ccc une
croissance us
jusqu'à l'été au moins donc on sait que
l'accord ne va pas s'inverser un
successeur nous avons fait une campagne
présidentielle j'avais un débat avec
nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande sur
la croissance
je vous rappelle les chiffres qu'il
donnait françois hollande disait nous
allons avoir une croissance en 2013 de
1,7 pour cent et nicolas sarkozy disait
nous aurons 2%
nous aurons 0% il n'est pas d'élection
depuis 20 ans où on ne dore la pilule
aux citoyens c'est à dire on les égards
on leur raconte des histoires est
d'accord mais là bout du compte ne lit
pas d'accord comment vous deviez dire
pas d'accord et je suis dans la réalité
finit toujours par rattraper certains
mensonges françois bayrou
et quand un françois hollande demande
aujourd'hui à être jugé à la fin du
quinquennat
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
pourront attendre je vais vous dire ce
que je pense c'est grave ou en tout cas
je le dis avec gravité
je pense que nous sommes assez près
d'une crise politique menaçante suffit
de voir le score des élections
partielles dimanche dans l'oise avec eux
une extrême droite qui fait 49% contre
le candidat de l'ump pour qui le ps
avait appelé à voter au niveau national
et donc il ya là quelque chose qui avec
45% des voix de gauche qui votent pour
l'extrême droite là en germe vous
parlais de danger d'une crise morale
politique non mais je dis que je dis que
les gens sont très près
deux attitudes et de choix et de vote
pour rejeter on dit le système pour
rejeter cette organisation des pouvoirs
et des partis dans lequel ils ne
trouvent aucun espoir
surtout que vous dites quand on a le
risque de crise majeure dans notre pays
effectivement quand une ya une crise
économique dont on ne voit pas l'issue
quand il y à préserver république et un
gouvernement qui est au plus bas dans
les dans les sondages est ce que le
pouvoir selon vous a perdu toute
légitimité d'ores et déjà
non je ne ne dit pas les choses comme ça
je veux dire une chose précise lorsque
ce n'est même pas l'impopularité qui est
la question
c'est le fait de pouvoir gouverner la
france c'est le fait de comprendre où on
va le la plus grave des légitimations né
il ya une des légines on est dans des
légitime l'action politique pourquoi
parce qu'elle est illisible et elle est
illisible pour une raison extrêmement
précise et que vous connaissez c'est que
la campagne qui a été fait et la
majorité qui est sortie des urnes sont
en contradiction flagrante avec la
politique qui doit être suivi il ya donc
une contradiction tenaille dans lequel
est le gouvernement et le président de
la république son prix vous avez voté
pour françois hollande qui assume quand
même son positionnement social démocrate
cdu attendait d'eux
lui concrètement par exemple jeudi il va
s'adresser aux français vous attendez
quoi un gérer les noms de pédagogie au
véritablement de nouvelles annonces
alors je ya une chose qui m'agace c'est
qu'on dise qu'il faut rassurer les
français ça tout le monde dit ça faut
pas rassurer les français
il faut organiser l'action et la
mobilisation du pays de l'état des
collectivités locales
elle s'appelle quel type de révision va
leur gibier dans le jeu via les grandes
options jeu gaz et exclut les terrains
ce qui me paraissait nécessaire pour
ceux qui sont en première ligne dakar
les entreprises et ce qui si les
contrats de travail pour me cherche
et pour françois hollande et les
innovateurs pour françois l'entretenir
noir deuxièmement il ya un enjeu qui
n'est pour l'instant pas dû tout assumer
c'est la moralisation de la vie publique
en france tout le monde voit bien les
débordements les promesses qui ont été
multipliés cumul des mandats
simplification de la démocratie locale
on disait nouvelle étape de
décentralisation mais ça peut pas aller
en gardant le labyrinthe que nous avons
au transfert des compétences
on a parlé d'un nouveau transfert on a
réparé volet collectivités de règles
électorales plus juste de tout ça n'est
prise en cours donc dont ils ont l'air
de moralisation de la vie baisse de ça
doit passer par par exemple un homme sur
ces questions là si le président de la
république estimé il ya des raisons de
le penser que le lait le parlement
actuel avec les députés les sénateurs ne
lui permettront pas d'obtenir
satisfaction
il faut qu'il fasse appel au peuple ça
lui permettrait peut-être d'ailleurs
d'avoir un nouveau rapport avec le
peuple d'accepter de prendre ces
problèmes
j'allais dire bille en tête telle
question faudrait-il posée sachant que
vous vous aviez déjà fait ces
suggestions lorsque vous étiez candidat
je viens alors qu'elle m'aurait fait si
j'avais été là nous quelle question des
zones arides où y'avait il ya pour moi
trois choses à mettre dans le référendum
le cumul des mandats la diminution du
nombre de parme
ter entre nous c'est pas mettre dans le
référendum mais vous pouvez pas
conserver un gouvernement avec 39 je
sais pas combien 38 ministres et des
cabinets plus tôt enfin tout ce qu'on
avait promis de changer 3e qui arrêtera
la règle électorale
il n'est pas possible vous avez vu les
résultats vous avez trois courants
principaux qui depuis une décennie
animent la vie du pays et ils sont pas
d'accord je suis pas d'accord avec tous
mais regardons l'extrême droite le front
national
l'extrême gauche et le centre ces trois
courants lors des dernières élections
présidentielles ont fait 40 % des voix
chaque fois ensemble ils n'ont pas de
représentant à l'assemblée trouvé sa
juste et bien jeudi qu' il n'y a aucune
raison que la loi organisant france des
sous citoyens dont je ne suis pas moi
qui suis du centre ou d'autres qui font
d'autres choix sont pas moins citoyens
que le parti socialiste et l'ump et même
et même entre nous ils ne sont un peu
plus parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de
voix par représentant que cela doit nous
les aimons ce maillot c'est clair c'est
clair mais absolument machault pose
quand même une question allez vous avez
aussi référendum serait la seule
condition aujourd'hui pour que le chef
de l'état soit re légitimer par dis pas
que c'est la seule celle là qu'on dise
je ne dis pas que c'est la seule
et si on ne fait pas la moralisation de
la vie publique et là le la mise en
action de toutes les forces du pays pour
soutenir les producteurs
l'action de power les artisans les
entreprises les pme les chercheurs les
innovateurs
si vous ne faites pas c'est deux choses
là d'accord les deux conditions dans les
organisations du pays pour me livrer la
guerre et moralisation de la vie
publique
en tout cas vous ne risquez pas de
réussir d'accord et pourquoi pas une
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
certains évoquent parce que dissous dans
la censure nationale sans avoir changé
la règle du jeu ça ne sert à rien on
vous en avait parlé avec
françois hollande oui vous avez des
échanges avec lui le dernier remonte
avant lui il ya quelques mois quelques
semaines quelques semaines maintenant
voilà alors il est ouvert ce que vous
proposez bon j'ai l'impression qu'il
voit bien en jeu après il ya une grande
question c'est est-ce qu'il franchit le
pas un ce qu'il a failli vous a pas
répondu l'audace de le faire et ceux ci
on verra dans quelques donc quelques
jours devraient me soumettre la
couverture de l'express cette semaine et
qui montre france hollande qui serre les
dents avec le titre la débâcle est ce
que nous en sommes là selon vous en tout
cas on est en situation de de
décomposition politique très importante
rue on est en situation la débâcle vous
savez c'est quand les glaces se se
fracture c'est généralement au printemps
d'ailleurs alors je dis pas qu'on en
soit là mais on est dans un moment où le
le peuple en arrive à un tel degré de
d'interrogations de doutes et même de
perte de confiance que les responsables
politiques devraient s'en inquiéter et
quand marine le pen voit le front
national en centre excusez moi quand ça
va le grand centre de gravité de la vie
politique aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle finit par dire ferait
bien j'ai dit dans ce livre que je ne
savais pas si on pourrait éviter une
poussée extrémiste
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
le pense ou que je le dis hein c'est
toute ma vie je me suis battu contre 7
ce risque cette fois ci le risque existe
vraiment mais il faut avoir une chose en
tête
si les extrêmes réussissait à l'emporter
vous aurez un accident grave pour le
pays un chaos une décomposition qui sera
infiniment dommageable et dangereuse
pour les plus fragiles du pays
ce que chaque fois que vous avez une
décomposition c'est les plus fragiles
qui trinquent et donc le jeu voit bien
que le risque il est pas seulement d'en
brandir des attitudes et des mots qui
sont excessifs le risque il est dans les
solutions proposées qui ne peuvent nous
conduire qu'à deux graves accidents
alors on va voir quelle quel rôle vous
vous pourriez jouer alors déjà vous
adresser au chef de l'état vous l'avais
dit dans les semaines et mois qui
viennent pour conjurer ce risque
évidemment morten pour la france on va
voir ça dans un instant avec pierre et
rockit cholly de l' agence france presse
qui nous rejoint mais d'abord donc votre
éloge de la vérité en politique qui a
inspiré jérôme ramier l'heure de vérité
vient je les dis aux français la vérité
ce discours de vérité de courage et de
responsabilité
je pense qu'on se sent respecté par
quelqu'un qui vous dit la vérité à la
vérité si grandes vertus dont tous les
politiques tentent depuis toujours de se
parer socrates déjà dans l'antiquité
était tombé malade après s'être impliqué
dans la vie politique de la cité
incompatible avec son intransigeance
morale qui l'empêchait de travestir la
réalité alors irréconciliables hommes
politiques et vérité c'est le grand
paradoxe des politiques c'est à dire que
tous les politiques prétendent parler au
nom de la raison prétendent argumenté
prétendre dire le vrai or ils ont tous
des opinions c'est à dire que l'idée
qu'ils se font de la vérité est
immédiatement biaisé par la certitude
qui est la leur par l'angle de vue qu'il
porte sur la vérité une vérité est
toujours be
zé par la façon dont on la regarde c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est très
difficile de parler de vérité ou de
parler en vérité tout en faisant de la
politique parce qu'il faut pour le faire
à la fin d'une vérité regarder la vérité
en face
regarder la vérité en face et ne pas
dire simplement une vérité que les gens
voudraient entendre
c'est la différence entre ce que le
philosophe michel foucault appelé le
very dire détacher de ses opinions et le
parler vrai qui n'est qu'une imposture
se parent de vérité pas sûr au final que
la politique est comme objectif la
manifestation de la vérité la vérité
n'est pas une finalité en politique la
finalité en politique c'est de proposer
un propos pour le pays de sorte
qu'ensemble ils regardent dans la même
direction
évidemment les français ne sont pas
dupes ils ne sont pas dupes d'ailleurs
de même il essaye de trouver le bon
équilibre entre le souhaitable et le
possible est le réel n'est en général
que je dirais la troisième composante
jamais un politique n'a ni avoir été
convaincu par le discours d'un
adversaire
ce serait faire preuve de faiblesse
quitte à avouer une vérité les débats
politiques ne sont donc pas de vraie
confrontation d'idées
si la vérité était accessible à
l'exercice politique on aurait des
débats objectivement contradictoire
c'est-à-dire dont chacun retirerait un
profit mais les individus en politique
ne sont pas là pour ça il représente
autre chose que la vérité c'est la
raison pour laquelle ceux qui se flatte
de dire la vérité de dire enfin la
vérité sont toujours des menteurs de
vous donner la possibilité de répondre à
l aile premièrement
r vrd menteur si vous l'avez lu oui oui
c'est pas certain mais si vous attendez
si vous l'avez lu ce je vous crois je
n'ai pas du tout je peux pas vous dire
la vérité je vais refaire des citations
référence il dira d'ailleurs dans
l'aviation
donc en dehors de ce sourire
le livre ne dis pas que je dis la vérité
ni que j'ai la vérité le livre dit c'est
vous devenir super bien des verrines à
la même heure de reprise est lente
c'est vrai ça le livre dit une chose
simple
il n'est pas de réformes possibles si
les citoyens et les gouvernants n'ont
pas entre eux un contrat de vérité c'est
ça que c'est pourquoi le titre du livre
n'est pas la vérité en politique parce
que françois bayrou la vérité en
politique ça aurait fait un peu
d'honneur voilà distributeur de leçons
il dit je vais parler de la vérité en
politique au sujet de la vérité aux
politiques pour faire un peu de latin
bon première chose deuxièmement vient de
voir un exercice très intéressant par
des gens que j'aime bien par ailleurs
mais c'est très simple ils sont contents
de la manière dont ça se passe ce qu'ils
ont défendu c'est qu'on continue comme
ça ta diritti ce ben c'est pas possible
de faire autrement on peut pas
s'accorder sur des vérités
d'ailleurs la vérité de là c'est pas la
véritable c'est à dire qu'on continue
comme on est or si on si on pense qu'on
peut continuer comme monde est à cette
émission n'a aucun sens à ce moment là
c'est recommençons l'ump ps on n'est pas
content de lui un pur mais le ps n'est
pas content du ps on met l'ump puis on
va recommencer dans six mois puisque de
toute façon les citoyens vont être
gruger au bout du chemin et donc le tout
le tout le ressort de ce livre c'est que
précisément je n'ai que je suis de ceux
nombreux qui n'acceptent pas que ça
continue comme ça
alors justement cette vérité ça a été
quand même un des thèmes le thème fort
de votre dernière campagne
présidentielle
bon vous êtes arrivé en cinquième
position avec moins de 10% des voix
avec pas loin de 10% des voix pas loin
des 10% dès fois je vous la corde
la vérité c'est aussi quand vous avez
vous est prononcée et vous avez assumé
votre vote en faveur de françois
hollande
ça vous a valu aux législatives d'être
d'être battu par une candidate
socialiste
oui c'est vrai la lotion c'est dire un
secret est ce que vous êtes
oui et en idées après les vérités les
secrets ans progresse encore si vous ne
voulez pas prendre de risque ne fait pas
de la politique
d'ailleurs si vous voulez pas prendre de
risque choisissez tout simplement de ne
pas vivre parce que la vie c'est le
risque
il y avait un humoriste qui disait que
la vie était une maladie sexuellement
transmissible et mortelle dans tous les
cas ce qui est probablement assez vrai
en tout cas pour la première partie je
suis sûr que c'est vrai la deuxième
partie nous vérifierons ensemble dans
quelque temps le plus tard possible mais
à l'aune de halandri autre exemple est
ce qu'on peut dire que la virilité paye
en politique ou pas probablement pas
probablement pas mais est ce que vous
faites de la politique pour que ça paye
c'est ça la question alors il ya
beaucoup de gens qui font de la
politique pour sa paye pour ça paye en
termes de carrière pour que ça paye en
termes d'honneur pour que ça paye en
termes de gloriole avait connu tout ça
vous le racontez servij oui disons que
je me tiens à vous être bien défendre
comme dit cyrano je me le cerf moi-même
avec assez de verve et je ne prétends
pas je ne permets pas qu'un autre venez
serbe
bon oui bien entendu si c'est ça que
vous cherchez alors faut pas prendre le
chemin que je suis mais si vous êtes non
pas un homme politique mais d'abord sans
vouloir employer de grands mots un homme
tout court
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui cherche à
rendre sa vie justifié
en père de famille c'est très important
mais j'ai été père de famille très jeune
et ça va marquer pour toute la vie c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui se sent une
responsabilité de transmission alors
vous ne cherchez ni les honneurs ni la
gloriole ni l'argent ni le succès vous
chercher l'essentiel pour l'avenir et
c'est précisément là que se situe mon
choix alors je reconnais qu'il est
minoritaire pour l'instant rôles tels
que vous voyez c'est celui d'une sorte
d'autorité morale vous citez souvent
dans votre livre vous citez raymond
barre vous citez madness france vous
voulez vous situez dans cette lignée
d'abord autorité morale c'est pas nul ou
mais ça n'est pas mon rôle d'abord j'ai
pas cette prétention
il ya un rôle qui est le mien
ces chapelles ça le roule ou la
responsabilité de conviction je n'ai pas
de rôle à l'action pour les très rares
qui sont au pouvoir vraiment et puis la
conviction pour ceux qui sont dans
l'opposition dans l'indépendance comme
moi c'est à dire cela leur boulot leur
mission c'est de s'adresser au peuple
des citoyens et de leur proposer des
issues des solutions que que que y voit
un peu plus clair pour leur avenir
qu'ils soient convaincus tout peut-être
il s'engage et qu'un jour ils aillent
dans la direction que l'on croît être la
plus juste et la meilleure c'est à dire
que vous avez relais renoncer à l'action
1 je n'ai pas ces annonces l'action mais
pour l'instant
fait l'issue des élections ne m'a pas
porté au pouvoir entre guillemets alors
vous attendez un électrochoc
j'ai compris le mot n'est pas sa
mauvaise je pense je pas bon alors
monsieur dans l'hebdomadaire marianne de
cette semaine on imagine un remaniement
qu'il a créé un électrochoc et on va
votre nom apparaître
françois bayrou se soyons fous aux
affaires européennes jouent mais cette
proposition sur la table mais il ya des
gens qui croient que le but de la vie
politique c'est d'entrer dans un
gouvernement
eh bien ce n'est pas le but de la mienne
vous me demandez est-ce que vous avez
l'arrière-pensée d'entrer dans le nom
c'est clair comme ça il y aura pas
d'hésitation non ce que je
j'attends et ce pour quoi je travaille
de toutes mes forces c'est que le
gouvernement comme la société comme
l'opinion publique change ces lignes
directrices qui l'ont amené où il est
aujourd'hui par exemple je pense que le
le fond des idées qui ont été celles de
la gauche ces dernières années était
erroné et je pense que l'exercice du
pouvoir va les obliger à chercher des
attitudes qu'ils soient des attitudes
plus juste
vous avez dit justement ce point le jour
où le peuple français a choisi la voie
courageuse de son redressement je serai
prêt à l'aider
bien sûr aller des commandes dans
n'importe quelle dans n'importe quelle
situation
je n'ai je ne je ne marchande pas vous
comprenez enfin vous le savez je vous
avais pas votre responsabilité de
journalistes participé à beaucoup
d'événements de la vie politique ces
dernières années je ne marchande pas je
ne cherche pas des chapeaux à plumes et
des galons sur les épaules et
du doré sur les boiseries de mon bureau
ça va très bien rien de tout ça alors je
sais bien qu'il ya beaucoup de gens que
cette attitude pourrait étonner c'est la
mienne c'est comme ça c'est c'est un
choix de vie
je n'ai pas envie de consacrer les les
années qui sont les miennes et les
forces qui sont les miennes à des choses
qui ne valent rien parce que les faucons
en appelant confession abbas et vous
c'est vous qui l'avez cherché le faut
pouvoir celui qu'on étale qu'on raconte
avec des photos des gardes du corps des
chauffeurs des limousines se fout
pouvoir ne m'intéresse pas s'ils n'y en
a qu'un dans la vie politique française
qui n'est pas intéressé par ce pouvoir
là s'il n'en reste qu'un ce sera moi
intéresse pas s'adresser aux français
par exemple jean luc mélenchon lui il
estime que le peuple a besoin de
dirigeants qui parle de rue et crut pas
pro de provoquer ce que vous pensez de
cette approche
oui je pense que par les drus c'est bien
manier l'insultent c'est plus discutable
tant jean luc mélenchon dit que
moscovici est un à la tribune
bon je trouve que fait dire par son bras
non pas du tout je l' ai entendu de mes
oreilles
il a dit j'appelle un chat enfin j'ai
bien le droit d'appeler un chat un chat
et mon camarade un salopards
c'est exactement la citation ça veut
dire appeler un chat un chat qu'est ce
que c'est c'est un chat est un chat je
lui donne le nom de chat donc ça veut
dire grâce à le par grâce à l'opac lui
donne le nombre de salles pas pour moi
en tout cas ça mérite qu'on réfléchisse
là où on va entraîner le débat alors je
vois bien ce que mélenchon essaie de
faire ce qu'il veut c'est créer alors à
l'image de ce que jean marie le pen
parce que c'était la pratique de jean
marie le pen à l'image de ce que jean
marie le pen faisait il a réfléchi à ça
et il s'est rendu compte que chaque fois
que jean marie le pen
passé les bornes d'une certaine manière
il captait des votes
eh bien je pense que la responsabilité
de citoyen même pas d'un homme politique
ou d'un homme d'état mais la
responsabilité d'un citoyen c'est
précisément de ne pas aller dans ce sens
là parce qu'il est très facile de mettre
le feu à une société gelé reproché hier
à d'autres qui étaient au pouvoir et je
continue à dire que ce n'est pas la
direction à suivre qu'elle est
périlleuse pour un pays en crise
christian clères oui alors juste pour
rebondir ce que vous venez de dire de
sur jean luc mélenchon vous aviez prédit
en possible un possible éclatement de la
gauche alain confronter à la réalité du
pays
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les attaques de jean luc mélenchon
vis-à-vis de moscovici vont dans le sens
de cet éclatement est ce que vous
franchement quelqu'un qui ne verraient
pas que cet éclatement est en cours
quand on mène quand on en met à
l'intérieur du même prétendu caen ou du
prétendu même quand on a mené à ce
traité de part à la tribune il ya
peut-être un paquet franchi oui il y a
une fracture en cours et cette fracture
elle est entre eux la gauche idéologique
et celles qui acceptent le réel comme il
est donc de ce point de vue là la vérité
c'est le réel
alors peut-être la question suivante est
ce que cette fracture va selon vous avez
bien réussi à doubler une grosse heure
il vous allez jouer à l'avenir sans le
cadre de cette fracture des gauches que
cette fracture va va enclencher
ouverture selon vous vers le centre non
ça m'aurait pas posé la question
le jour où il y aura une vraie politique
réformiste dans notre pays
il faudra une majorité réformiste mais
elle va plus loin que le centre il y a
dans la droite républicaine
des responsables politiques qui sont
tout à fait au fond sur le fond sur la
même ligne et c'est cette majorité là
qui est absente et dont l'absence a
faibli toute possibilité de politique
réelle et imminente cette île est
imminente cet éclatement au a envoyé
certains au terme de mois d'inventaire
nomme deux mois c'est à une précision
importante merci ça veut dire que ça
nous allah namibien jusqu'aux
municipales et européennes sont douze
mois cette année là elle va être
extrêmement perturbé perry alors voilà
on va aller plus loin maintenant avec
perrine tarneaud qui va nous rejoindre
sur cette refondation du paysage
politique que vous annoncez dans les
mois qui viennent françois bayrou
d'abord avec alexandra colinot on
s'interroge encore sur votre avenir et
sur votre éventuel rebond et ses genoux
le sujet depuis cinq ans françois bayrou
a perdu toutes ces élections municipales
présidentielle législative beaucoup au
modem son parti formé un autre centre
d'autres ont été licenciés faute de
financement le bateau a pris l'eau lui a
entamé sa traversée du désert pas la
première ce solitaire de la république
ne s'en inquiète pas comme l'a observé
le journaliste samir tounsi françois
bayrou va voir 62 ans il est juste un
peu plus jeune que le général de gaulle
lors de sa traversée du désert période
non mais après 1954 et parfois françois
bayrou doit peut être comparée border
son village des pyrénées à colombey en
se disant que l'issue sera la même un
retour au pouvoir
un parallèle que françois bayrou ne
boude pas évoquant aussi mendès-france
ou churchill des comparaisons à la
hauteur de la fois que l'homme en son
destin double car le président du modem
se voit en pionnier oui il ya de ça il
ya les pionniers il ya des premiers de
cordée et diallo te de lower de chevet
voilà de dreux ouvrir un chemin qui
existe doit recréer heures pour
retrouver le lorrain chemins de
l'histoire
reste à savoir si la solitude de
françois bayrou durera jusqu'à l'
isolement ou lui servira pour assembler
la voix la perrine tarneaud nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau alors après une
confession un come as you are in on va
peut-être également revenir à notre
question politique on a pris le palais
est ce que peut dire un mot oui parce
que très souvent scène mais opposé ce
qu'on peut dire en un mot qui a pas de
solitude jamais vécu la solitude parce
que j'ai toujours eu des millions de
français avec moi et j'ai toujours eu
autour de moi une équipe qui est solide
forte courageuse réseau de nombreux
devoirs solitude parlementaire voilà
j'accepte cette encore que j'ai autour
de moi des députés on vient d'en voir un
des sénateurs
vous le savez dans la haute assemblée
des parlementaires européens mais disons
oui nous entourer de figures tutélaires
commando quand vous parlez de barre de 2
go
vaut mieux avoir des grands comme
exemple que des médiocres vous souvenez
quand même dans votre livre que ce sont
aussi tous des perdants en terme
électoral
ouais bah oui sont perdants par moment
et est bon c'est pas déshonorant jeu
j'ai été frappé de quelque chose dans
pas quelque chose en écrivant ce livre
j'ai cherché qui étaient les gagnants
autant de mendès-france qui alors il
s'appelait guy mollet il s'appelait
laniel il s'appelait félix gaillard nous
sommes 50 ans ou 60 ans après de qui
parle-t-on
ce sont des noms complètement oublié
peut-être pas parce qu'il manquait de
talent simplement parce qu'ils ont
accepté de ne pas marquer l'histoire
qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux marquer
l'histoire aux marques et peut-être la
vie quotidienne des gens en étant utile
dans un gouvernement
ça c'est une vraie question s'il
s'agissait d'être utile dans un
gouvernement la question ne se poserait
pas mais pour la plupart de ceux que
nous évoquons il s'agit d'être inutile
dans un gouvernement inutile vous dites
oui effectivement amener ça ne sert à
rien jeudi me suis tu parce que moi
j'étais à la tête d'un département
ministériel qui a la chance d'être
complètement autonome si j'ose dire de
l'éducation on n'a pas besoin ou
heureusement je n'ai pas eu besoin de
mettre en scène tous les jours le faut
pouvoir
mais jeudi en effet le l'essentiel de ce
qu'on croit être le pouvoir est une
duperie ses mises en scène et si vous
leur parlez en vérité en dehors des
caméras des mitrons ceux qui l'exercent
où l'on exercé encore plus vous diront
bien sûr c'était donc c'est ça ne
marquait pas en profondeur les choses
est ce que je voudrais moi c'est qu'on
en revienne à du vrai pouvoir
c'est à dire pas faire semblant que dans
une baguette magique qui change tout
mais à la capacité d'entraîner les gens
quand jean lassalle dit il faut qu'il
recrée un
demain quelle est votre stratégie de
reconquête il parle dans le sujet du
petit chemin vert peut-être la ville de
pau qui mènera après aux grands chemins
la présidentielle un jeu je n'ai aucune
envie de parler déchéance locales ici ni
même de parler des chances et électorale
c'est dans 14 mois 12 mois pour les
municipales qui tournoient alain
européenne est franchement dans l'année
qui vient il va se passer tellement de
choses que je recommande à ceux qui font
des plans sur la comète de terrassement
prochain il fallait pas que ça va
connaître ton oui mais les gens qui
m'aiment ils ont de bien entendu envie
de deux succès de bonheur pour moi mais
là n'est vraiment pas l'essentiel
quelques questions d'actualité en parler
d'éducation à l'instant sur la réforme
des rythmes scolaires qui va donc
s'appliquer en ordre dispersé à partir
de la rentrée 2013 est ce que finalement
il n'y a plus une école publique
nationale mais autant de particularités
locales municipales je veux dire quelque
chose qui va me faire mal voir les
rythmes scolaires
c'est je veux pas dire second père mais
secondes c'est pas là que se joue
l'avenir de l'école suffirait d'ajouter
deux semaines de classe pour que se
trouve régler la plupart des problèmes
qui se posent
c'est pas là que ça ce jour j'ai lu le
texte de du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée deux soi-disant re fondation
de l'école ou prétendument pour parler
français refondation de l'école 80 pages
et je sais pas combien de pages
d'annexés peut-être une centaine de
brillantes addex en tout cas à mon sens
c'est pas une refondation donc il à côté
de la plaque vincent p 1
non il va essayer de mettre dans un
texte qui n'est pas lisible
la plupart des revendications ou des
obsessions des uns et des autres au bout
du compte qu'est ce qui reste
les 60000 postes il ya des gens qui
croient que c'est avec 60000 postes
qu'on va changer l'école je ne le crois
pas
je crois pas que ce soit une question de
moyens il reste les rythmes scolaires et
je vous ai dit ce que j'en pensais et il
reste toute une série de suppressions
ce2 d'organiser ce 2e et de règles
d'organisation de l'école qu'on ne
remplace pas rien j'en cite deux on a
supprimé les cycles vous savez si ray
ceux qui ont des enfants savent qu'à
l'école primaire et au collège
il ya des cycles qui comprenait deux
années où on essayait de faire aller
plus vite les uns et un peu voilà en
lait on les supprime
et on supprime une disposition qui était
utile qui était que des élèves qui
n'aimait pas l'abstrait puis se choisir
l'apprentissage tôt pour le suppléer on
ne remplace pas rien a plaidé ségolène
royal s'est beaucoup élevé contre s
était bien à la raison il se trouve que
nous sommes du même avis sur ce point
parce qu'il ya des élèves que
l'organisation de l'école et
l'abstraction qui sont pas faits pour ça
et non il ne s'est pas qu'ils sont pas
fait peut-être qu'ils auraient été faits
mais en tout cas un moment donné ya un
blocage
eh bien je trouve que c'est une idée qui
est depuis longtemps refusée par un
certain nombre d'organisations
je pense que c'est pas bien de la
supprimer sans la remplacer par rien
aérienne
françois bayrou est ce que nicolas
sarkozy paraît selon vous membres du
conseil constitutionnel depuis sa mise
en examen dans l'affairé bettencourt ça
n'a rien à voir
je pense que la difficulté nicolas
sarkozy au conseil constitutionnel comme
les pour les autres présidents c'est que
ils ont à prendre des décisions qui
concernent des lois qu'ils ont eux mêmes
fait voter donc il navré tout est donc
je suis pour que l'on trouve une autre
un autre statut aux anciens présidents
de la république sont chères du conseil
constitutionnel tracas il est légitime
qu'on leur garantisse un statut tous les
pays du monde aux anciens chefs de
l'état garantisse un statut
une équipe de collaborateurs peut-être
des bureaux et un statut qui leur
permettent de bon ça c'est légitime mais
en faire des membres du conseil
constitutionnel dans la nouvelle
définition du conseil constitutionnel
c'est-à-dire devenue une juridiction
cour suprême une cour suprême est par
exemple comme le propose monsieur oui
moi je pense que je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire
je pense que il est il n'est pas sain
que des hommes qui ont eu la
responsabilité de proposer et de faire
voter des lois est ensuite à juger de
leur constitutionnalité en revendant
val-andré le par oui je le répète mais
il faut leur faire un statut n'y a
aucune raison que je lisais l'autre jour
que l'un d'entre eux parce qu'ils
avaient des difficultés n'avait plus
d'indemnités donc une raison il ya
aucune raison tout ça n'est pas sérieux
n'est pas responsable dans ses rayons un
ancien chef de l'état en france doit se
voir assurer une sur un statut pour pour
l'assurer que les deux questions très
rapide 1 pour finir en reparle beaucoup
de laïcité après la décision la cour de
cassation dans la sphère de la crèche
baby loup est ce que vous êtes favorable
ou à une loi contre les ports contre le
port du voile dans les entreprises
privées qui accueille notamment des jeux
je pense que nous avons des lois elles
sont déjà suffisamment difficile à
impliquer appliquons les et faisons le
bilan après contre le rejet du texte sur
le mariage gay qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la part des sénateurs
centristes notamment du modem
ici au sénat le texte aille de la
personne indique tous les sénateurs
j'attends que ils réfléchissent
attentivement à la double attente que ce
texte aurait dû satisfaire les attentes
de ceux qui pensent ou afaki qui
espère une reconnaissance et des droits
et c'est légitime et la tante de ceux
qui s'inquiètent de voir un des piliers
de la société fragilisée
est ce que le texte peut être encore un
bébé selon vous et vos nerfs que soutien
des centristes savait trop comment
autrement
excusez moi à quoi le sénat servir et
qui ma mère avant de se faire une idée
du sens à votre vote avant moi je j'ai
déjà exprimées ce vote
mais je vais le je vais reprendre on dit
que le sénat c'est la chambre de la
sagesse du recul par rapport à
l'actualité qui peut entendre des choses
que le reste du parlement ne peut pas
n'aurait il ya un moment où on peut
réfléchir à la manière dont ce texte
pourrait répondre aux attentes des uns
et ne pas ignorer les inquiétudes des
autres par exemple sur l'affiliation sur
la filiation prennent merci notamment un
merci beaucoup monsieur bayrou d'avoir
été avec nous donc on a compris de la
vérité en politique toujours chez votre
éditeur plon merci à tous et à très vite
une semaine politique et parlementaire
passé au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème
n'existait pas et maintenant un problème
la crise écologique et plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour te comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
quand on accompagne sorties scolaires
il ya le principe de neutralité et le
principe de laïcité
la laïcité est une valeur essentielle de
la république française mais que
signifie ce concept si abstrait ses
partisans défendent ils tous les mêmes
idées mettre de côté équipé lui
différencier les uns des autres
c'est cela qui permet le vivre ensemble
il ya une nouvelle la licité car cherche
à appliquer aux individus du moins
certains d'entre eux et ça alors ça me
paraît être une atteinte à la liberté de
conscience à l'école au travail ou dans
la rue comment une notion aussi
abstraite se décline dans la société
vous avez dit laïcité samedi à 15h15 sur
public sénat
tablettes smartphones internet mobile le
numérique est partout et même dans
l'esprit de françois hollande c'est le
quatrième engagement de son programme
présidentiel
une ambition numérique qui passe par
l'installation du réseau très haut débit
en france le réseau thd 50% du
territoire couvert dans 5 ans 100 % dans
dix ans une révolution technologique
pour soigner la fracture numérique
car aujourd'hui en france le réseau
internet connaît des faiblesses la
france est en train de prendre un retard
considérable par rapport au reste du
monde et même à l'intérieur de la zone
européenne par rapport aux peuples de
l'est nous sommes en train de prendre du
retard
aux côtés de son collègue ump pierre
hérisson le sénateur yves rome s'est vu
confier une mission d'information par le
sénat fixer les conditions de cette
numérisation du territoire le très haut
débit une priorité un élément
indispensable pour bien vivre dans les
territoires au même titre que l'eau ou
l'électricité mais aussi une révolution
économique la fibre peut redonner de
l'attractivité à la france relancer la
compétitivité
il faut aller très vite à la vitesse de
la lumière à la vitesse de la fibre
optique
le très haut débit par la fibre c'est
une aubaine pour un secteur celui des
entreprises
le e-commerce le commerce sur internet
est en plein boom comme ici dans l'oise
chez alfa direct service le numéro un de
la logistique en e-commerce
après votre shopping sur internet c'est
ici que vos commandes sont traitées
emballé et expédier ses petits sites
arrivent la fibre optique qui a changé
en fait le le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et qui nous a permis de
recueillir de plus en plus de
commerçants et de gérer de plus en plus
de commandes par jour et pour se rendre
compte de l'impact du thd sur les
communications de l'entreprise visite du
sénateur rome
ici le volume de données et de plus en
plus importants grâce à la fibre
le chiffre d'affaires de la ds a triplé
la fibre optique nous a permis de
développer notre activité et de
développer nos process pour gérer de
plus en plus de commandes par heure
et de la meilleure façon également pour
les employés et de traiter le la
commande de plus simplement possible
la fibre optique et l'optimisation des
process en interne nous permet
aujourd'hui de gérer plus de 9000
commandes par heure avant la fibre
c'était 100 commandes par jour
une véritable révolution et ce n'est pas
le numéro un de la vente en ligne de
chaussures qui dira le contraire
le site spécialisé a trouvé chez ads une
efficacité pour ses clients une rapidité
d'exécution
un client sarenza peut commander jusqu'à
15 heures et il recevra son prix le
lendemain matin avec la fibre et avec
l'ensemble des fonctionnalités que l'on
met en place et des pros c'est ce que
l'on met en place au niveau nos
entrepôts on est capable aujourd'hui de
concurrencer les plus gros sites
e-commercants du monde en termes de
logistique très haut débit fibre optique
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un fil de
verre très fin
enveloppé dans une gaine de protection
sa capacité véhicule est un signal
lumineux à la vitesse de la lumière
la différence avec les anciens câble
type adsl c'est le débit 100 fois plus
élevés sur des milliers de kilomètres
aujourd'hui en france on compte deux
cent cinquante mille abonnés à la fibre
optique
quand certains pays ont déjà achevé
leurs déploiements et pour comprendre
les enjeux au sénat yves rome reçoit les
acteurs de la filière
aujourd'hui il auditionne les fabricants
et installateurs de fibres on voit très
bien développement du des réseaux fibre
optique et infrastructures à fibre
optique et les services associés des
services très haut débit associés comme
un enjeu équivalent à celui
d'électrification de pays au début du
20e siècle
par ailleurs on fabrique des câbles
électriques là on a un bon parallèle
devant nous et on voit très bien comment
se sont structurés les réseaux
électriques
dans les 50 dernières années et comment
devrait se structurer les réseaux fibre
optique selon ces industriels
cette technologie est indispensable dans
chaque foyer français
quand vous avez la fille chez vous c'est
mon cas vous voyez pourquoi vous en avez
besoin tout simplement s'est arrêté dix
ans vous arrêtez de vous disputer avec
vos enfants et cetera pour savoir qui
trafiquent bon ça diraient que c'est le
petit le petit bout de la lorgnette
c'est celle c'est le sait la vision déjà
actuelle mais alors demain n'en parle
même pas aujourd'hui dans le monde juste
derrière les leaders japonais et
américains en matière de fabrication
les français sont depuis longtemps près
et il est vrai qu'en france
j'aimerais aujourd'hui c'était une
ancienne usine alcatel groupe
c'est une usine qui a développé à
l'époque plus de 300 brevets actifs
seulement 60